everything worthwhile
is uphill now the problem is
[Music]
we have downhill habits
now if you have downhill habits and you
have uphill hopes
you're in trouble
and the only way that you go uphill is
by self-discipline so listen to me very
carefully
it's impossible for you to have
continuous success without having
self-discipline in your life
impossible
[Music]
and my greatest challenge as a leader is
your greatest challenge as a leader
and that is every day
keeping people climbing
because they don't want to climb they
want the coast
to success
huh are you with me they want it to come
to them
they treat it like the lottery and they
just kind of hope that if they're the
right place at the right time
something wonderful will happen to them
it won't
everything worthwhile is uphill all the
way all the way not not
partially uphill and and the challenge
that we all have is we don't mind
climbing up hill for three or four days
as long as we can coast for a couple
i just i deserve a break i deserve a
break i deserve a break
see what you don't understand is four
days of climbing
is wiped out with one day of coasting
and you're back to the same place that
you were
and you wonder why you're not being
successful
it's faster downhill than it is uphill
it's easier downhill than is uphill
it's quicker downhill that is uphill
and so what happens is we have
a lot of good uphill days but we have a
few downhill days
and a few downhill days cancel out all
the uphill days
every day serve
someone every day
every day add value to people every day
serve one every day
live the intentional life of of doing
for others sometimes what they cannot do
for themselves
and if you will put people first and add
value to them and serve them it becomes
absolutely amazing what you and i are
going to have and achieve
how we're going to help people and in
return how it comes back to us benjamin
franklin said this
no one is useless in this world who
lightens the burden
of someone else if you're if you're
helping someone else lift a load in your
life
you become a very useful free person
manhattan godly said
that the best way to find yourself is to
lose yourself in the service of others
the word today is mindset
doug welton from clearwater floor
florida who is a coach and a counselor
sent the word mindset in and doug
you and i both know that how a person
thinks
is going to determine almost everything
about his or her success in fact
here's what i say to you and to all of
my friends
when i teach about success i think the
greatest gap in the world between
successful and unsuccessful people
is the thinking gap i think successful
people
think differently not better maybe even
not smarter
but differently than unsuccessful people
i have never known a person who was a
life coach
a leader a successful person at all
that didn't understand the power of
thinking that's why doug
every day in the morning i look at my
schedule
and i think and ask myself this question
what's the most important person i want
to see what's the most important event
i'm going to see
and then participate in because i want
to make sure that i maximize my day in
the
evening i reflect and i say okay
how did my day go and i go through my
whole hour by our calendar why
because here's what i know if we go
through our
day without thinking we will go through
our
out our day without being successful and
sowing the seeds that we need
that can reap the harvest that only a
good mindset
can bring to us but if you ask me my
favorite way
to learn here it is
nothing is more fun to me than to get i
don't know three
five people maybe max that are really
just good in an area they're just good
in a certain area
and we get together and we spend a
couple three hours just talking about
the subject that they're good in
so for example if i'm with people that
are good communicators i just love to
sit for three or four hours and
and and and chew on communication i mean
i mean throw that subject out and just
you know just be like a puppy to
just chew on that thing and and you know
one person talks a while another person
talks and
and and what i've discovered is that's
my favorite way of learning in fact
here's what i know
you give me three four people that are
really good on a subject and let us get
together and discuss it for three or
four hours
and it will be the quickest the most
effective and the most rounded way of
learning i can pull together
because i get enough adversity and
difference in
opinions and and yet skill set being
strong
that it's going to take and wherever i
am it's going to make it it's going to
make it so much better
so here's the challenge i have for you
in my book uh
on on thanking for a change or how
successful people think today
i talk about shared thinking and the
value of
of getting a few people together and and
to talk about something that's vital
you know i love to ask questions and so
how i direct conversation is by asking
questions i ask a question an area that
i want to talk about
and away we go and here's what i know
you take any thought that you have i
just just trust me on this
in fact i want you to try this out take
something that you think is just a good
thought
i mean maybe you've spent a couple of
months thinking about it working it's a
good idea it's a good thought
whatever that is work it to its maximum
until you think you have just taken that
thought and just
wrung it out i mean you have got that
baby down good
then get three or four people to sit
with you for a couple of hours
and share with them that idea and say
give me your thoughts about that and
let's see if we can improve
what i'm thinking i'm going to promise
you something
every time not most times not usually
every time
within 30 minutes you'll have thoughts
about that idea that you never had
before
they'll improve it in ways that you
could have never improved in fact you'll
say
oh my goodness they've taken me so much
further than i could have gotten by
myself i'd like to talk to you on the
principle
of being coachable or i may even
use another term here because it's
really the same
being teachable you see a person that is
coachable or teachable
the characteristic of that is the fact
that they want to learn
and the key is they want to learn
when i look at a person and i try to
determine what their capacity is
as a leader how far can they go how much
can they do
i sometimes look at their ability and
that will help and tell me a lot because
what they've accomplished in their past
tells me
at least what they can accomplish in the
present and i can build off of that
but the question is more than just what
is their ability and what have they done
the question is what is their attitude
you see when i look at a person i have
to ask myself
can she do this and will she do this
can is all about ability and will is all
about attitude
and a person that's coachable a person
that's teachable
they not only do the will they do they
can
they do them both they have the ability
and they have the attitude and there's
nothing
that takes you and helps you reach your
potential more
than to utilize both i've known people
that didn't have the ability but they
had a great attitude
and so you love them but they could only
go so far i've known people who had
great ability but they didn't have the
teachable spirit
and attitude and so therefore they could
have gone a long way but they go only a
short way but when a person has
both then all of a sudden
things begin to change i wrote a book
several years ago called talent is never
enough and the reason i wrote the book
is because there are a lot of talented
people but they're not coachable
they're not teachable and because of
that they put a limit on
what they are able to do what i've
discovered about
a teachable coachable person is this
they're not only a joy to work with
but they will maximize and utilize every
opportunity in every door for personal
growth in their life
so the question of how far you can go
how far can i go
how much can we accomplish what can we
do
that question really goes back to how
coachable
are we you see i'm 70 today
and i'm still learning why am i still
learning
because i want to learn i want to be
taught
i want to be coached i want you
i want somebody to walk into my life and
share with me how i can be better
how i can do more how can i go farther
how can i expand my potential
it's the extra plus in personal growth
beyond ability coachability
will take you further than anything else
what is that
power of connection well i think first
of all
it's valuing people
you know you have a incredible
incredible work here and
every person here in this studio makes
it happen
and one is too small of a number to
achieve greatness
and and the moment that you understand
that the people that you have around you
they're you know they're either
your number one asset or to be honest
with they could be your number one
liability
but the moment that you understand that
and begin to value people
i think that is what creates the
connection
because the moment that um i think we
all know don't you tom think
don't you think you know when a person
values you and and when a person doesn't
value you
and and so i think that giving value to
people
and expressing that to them is the
common ground that builds relationships
and so
yeah when i came in the studio i wanted
to meet everybody because
you've got an incredible successful
program and i want to meet the people
who
help you be who you are the person
learns to lead by practicing leadership
and at a very early age i was practicing
leadership
and so it all comes together and then
when i began to realize everything rises
and falls on leadership i became
really intentional tom of developing my
leadership skills
so i can remember for example i was
probably i don't know maybe 26 i heard
earl nightingale say on a tape that
if you would spend one hour a day every
day
on one subject for five years you could
become an expert on that subject
so i said wow i want to become an expert
in leadership so for the next five years
you know i spent an hour every day
reading about leadership talking to
leaders asking leaders questions
practicing leadership but it really was
consistent and when i started that
process
i i was thinking five years earl like i
said i could become an expert in five
years okay wow actually leadership
expert hello
and and so i kept you know i was kind of
like doing countdown five years four
years three years
i'm thinking i'm cape canaveral okay but
something happened to me about halfway
through that five year process
instead of keeping asking myself how
long will it take how long will it take
how long will it take one day i began to
realize
how i was growing as a leader and the
change that was happening within me
and i stopped asking the question how
long will it take and i started asking
the question
how far can i go and everything changed
that day
i realized that you can set goals and
have five year goals
whatever but but i i changed from a goal
mindset to a growth mindset
and the fact that if i would be
intentional in the areas of growth
that would have the return and and would
fit who i was
then i could really be successful and
help a lot of people i would wish for
every one of you today as a coach
to really become a confident
person if you want a marketing plan
nothing sells like confidence
nothing once you're confident and you
truly know
that you can help people once you truly
know that you can add value i can tell
you
i can look people right in the eye and i
can say with all the integrity world
trust me i can take you to a whole new
level in your life i'm not bs in them
i'm not delusional on drugs i
know and guess what they do
they buy into that confidence
so i began to ask myself what are the
confidence killers
if we're gonna grow in it we gotta know
where to clear the weeds don't we
the number one confidence killer is low
self-image
i don't think i can
rises from a deeper i don't think i am
i don't think i can
rises from a deeper i don't think i am
lower self-worth translates into 37
less willingness to negotiate
and use of 11 fewer negotiation
strategies
increased self-worth correlates with a
greater willingness to incur the risk
of prolonged negotiation and greater
adaptability
it's just this is a powerful statement
on negotiation you won't even go and
negotiate
if you don't have the confidence in
short the less confidence you have in
yourself
the faster you will give up trying to
get what you want
that's a fact when i see a person that
quits quickly
they have low self-confidence low
self-esteem
that's why they quit
fear is another killer of confidence
you see confidence comes from not always
being right
but not fearing to be wrong
when you run into a confident person the
confident person isn't always right
they just don't fear being wrong i can
tell you every day
i'm confident about a lot of decisions
now some of the decisions i'm confident
about aren't the best decisions
but i don't look at myself and say well
what happens if i fail what happens if
i'm wrong
i it doesn't bother me i don't fear that
failure
there's a popular cliche that says you
don't
know what you can do until you try
i like that you never try until you know
what you can do
confidence releases the risk
you can't grow yourself if you don't
know yourself
so i think awareness is huge you have to
be aware of
of yourself uh strengths weaknesses you
know the whole deal
and once you're aware of yourself then
you have to take your giftedness and and
and and maximize your strengths and then
you have to make the right choices
and but awareness is on the front end
and we don't hear a lot about awareness
how can you develop awareness well first
of all
i think you need other people's help i i
hear people all the time say well i
think i'm very self-aware and i always
get amused with that because
we're not you know we all have blind
spots i have blind spots
so if there's any self-awareness for me
it's because i've had somebody speak
into my life and and one more thing on
character okay
i was i was having an interview with a
major ceo
of of a large large software company
and so i asked him i said talk to me
about your failures like i do in my
learning lunches
this was on an executive circle called
where i was on the phone and and other
executives were
listening so i said talk to me about
your
failures i said um what would you like
to go in your life
and do over you know get the do-overs
what what what's your top
do-over he said something very
interesting to him he said well
he said i've made i've had failures and
i've had a lot of mistakes made some
wrong decisions
but i don't think i want to do any of
them over
i said you're kidding me you mean if you
could go back and correct a failure or
mistake
you wouldn't want to go back correctly
he said no he said
the lessons i learned out of my failures
probably are a lot more valuable than if
i had just made a successful decision
and moved on
he said who i am today is based upon
not having do-overs and learning out of
my
adversity and difficulty and struggles
and darkness
and i thought it was a fantastic answer
it really
talked to me a lot and i thought to
myself i think that's a perfect example
of leaders building character
out of their failure and out of their
adversity
and one of the things i shared with him
with this year that we've just gone
through
is that that um that a crisis is a
detour
in other words what a crisis is is it
takes us out of our rhythm
and out of our way of doing things and
and all of a sudden
the way that we're familiar with the way
that we understand the way that we
appreciate is taken from us and we're
now going a different way
it's a detour and in fact i i've been
encouraging everybody enjoy the detour
tour
and the reason you want to enjoy it is
because you're seeing things that you've
never seen before you're going places
you've never been before you're
experiencing things
you've never experienced before and this
is where the learning and the growing of
life
becomes so so so take the detour do it
here's the statement
everything everything that you
want or need but you don't have
stay with me everything that you want or
you need but you don't have it
it's outside of your comfort zone
that's why you don't have it if it was
in your comfort zone you'd already have
it you would say oh my gosh i need that
so
i'm going to go get it you take it you
move on the only reason that we don't
get it
is because it's out of our comfort zone
and and
what's so beautiful is people are out of
their comfort zone right now they're all
on the detour tour whether they want to
be or not
and it's an incredible time for
transformation and here's why
because when people are hurting that's
when they're willing to make their most
important changes in life
how do we create an environment of trust
it's essential in families it's
essential in communities
it's essential in business trust
needs to be the core the center
the fabric of any culture
i'm going to share with you now four
this is the most practical part of the
lesson right here i want to share with
you
four ways to create an environment of
trust
and what's so beautiful about what i'm
about to share is every one of you in
the auditorium
can do this we all can do this
it's not out of a reach it's not
something that's impossible
so look at your neighbor before i give
you the four things and say to them
even you can do this go ahead and tell
them that even you can do this
are you ready let's go number one we're
creating now a trust environment
which is conducive for transformation
number one value people a trust
environment
begins when people
feel valued number two if you want to
have an
environment of trust add value to people
this is all about influence this is
where
now i began to increase my influence by
adding
value to people let me give you an
example when i was a pastor
and i was writing books and and much to
my surprise when my publisher shared
with me that my books were being written
by the business community
much more than the community than the
christian community i i was totally
surprised i had no idea i
shocked beyond belief
and at that moment i felt called to go
and have my mission field the secular
community i
it was at that moment that i knew that i
would not pastor much longer that i
would have to spend the rest of my life
basically with lost people and so i
began to ask myself how do i connect
with these people
how do i influence these people and i
realize the only way to influence them
people and grow
and influence strength with them is to
add value to them
help them grow their business help them
grow leaders help them develop
and so i put a hundred percent into
helping people helping people serving
people
adding value making a difference in
their lives
number three if you want to create this
type of an
environment you have to live good values
and that's all about attracting
people number four share good values
that's where the transformation
the transformation begins when we share
good values and and the four ways to
have a
create this kind of an environment value
people add value to people live good
value share good values it's
it's it's all there folks it's all there
it's all about values
if you want some amazing affirmations
with jordan peterson check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there what i was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and
the split and i've actually had students
tell me the same thing has happened to
them